c'est quoi un maître international aux
échecs et bien c'est le deuxème titre le
plus prestigieux qui existe derrière
celui de grand maître pour réaliser cet
exploit il faut euh parvenir à faire
trois normes de maître international
c'est quoi une norme c'est une
performance dans un tournois on va
affronter au moins ne9u joueurs et il
faut réussir une paire Flo à minimum
2450 en plus de cela il faut que parmi
nos neuf adversaires il y ait deux
autres fédérations représentées que la
un autre et au moins trois d'entre eux
qui sont minimum titrés maître
international donc grand maître ça
marche aussi si toutes ces conditions
sont réunies on réalise une norme de
matre il en faut trois pour obtenir le
titre et dépasser la barre des 2400 ho
il en existe dans le monde actuellement
4027 et en France seulement 128